ah look at all the sweet stuff I got
from e3 last week would you get Malik
this stupid tiny sword are you happy
yeah
hey guys I'm Michelle morrow and i'm
malik forte and this is e stream
bleacher report's daily esports shell
covering the big topics that we care
about in competitive gaming now 33 years
over we're going to be taking a deep
dive into all the major esports
announcements which includes the return
of an OG quick champions as well as the
announcement of xbox live's new arena
future we also have a-league's Jason
Moses o'toole drop it into toc cska all
right look do this guy one of the
biggest eSports announcement at e3 last
week was the return of an OG you know
Michelle when I think of the early days
of competitive gaming one getting that
certainly comes them off from me quake
that's true and quake luckily has been
resurrected by Bethesda and it and
they're calling it quick champion the
big question here Malik is it is it too
late for quake to be a viable eSports
title right now I mean it's an older
game the younger generation isn't as
familiar with it as the older generation
do you think it will be successful I
mean when you look at all the
competitive shooters out there right now
they're all team-based and I think what
quake has its different is this a single
player free-for-all per se you know I
think that's what's good for anybody who
wants to get into this eSport it's way
more cost effective because you don't
have to worry about an entire team and
funding all these guys that's putting it
into a house or anything like that all
you have to do is worry about you know
single player so I think all these guys
with big egos these dudes who think
they're the fastest have the best twitch
reactions they're gonna want to hop
forward to this you know and we did not
forget the first-ever millionaire pro
gamer came out of the quake community
Jonathan fatality so I think it's gonna
be huge thinks I things we cool to have
like quake and get its spotlight right
now because right now is one America and
here in the states were releasing this
like surges of eSports and how exciting
it is so I'm Stokes that quake is able
to live in that line yes yeah I know I'm
like I'm liking that arena shooters or
becoming the thing again we're becoming
the thing anyways what do you guys think
will quake champions be successful as in
eSport let us know by tweeting us
at BR underscore e-string microsoft is
also getting into the eSports scene with
our new xbox live arena feature now what
this is is a place where competitive
gamers single players or teams can sync
up sign up and compete it also allows
gamers to build brackets and award
prizes so I guess the big question here
is how is this system going to impact
tournament organizers people like ESL or
just smaller tournament organizers will
this help will this compete what do you
think I don't think this is gonna impact
them on a grand scale but uh I do think
that this is a good idea for Xbox you
know I personally think that console
gamers need some love all right they
didn't has enough and this is a great
access point for people who want to get
involved in competitive gaming so if
you're playing gears of war or if you're
playing World of Tanks or any of those
games now you have an access point you
have a place you can go you can find
teammates you can learn about how
competitive games work you know you can
feel the adrenaline yeah competition I'm
excited for a title like smite because
might like has so much love on the pc
I'd like to see more for the console
gamer yes I'm excited for them for that
it is a great move by xbox just to say
hey we care about eSport right and it's
easy it's accessible it's intuitive I
mean I'm interested to see more about
the UI what they're going are you sure
yeah but it's better than having to go
to gamebattles calm or you know go on
ESL cops are there are some differences
there and I do like the fact that it's a
little bit easier yeah definitely well
are you guys planning to use the arena
feature when it launches on xbox live
let us know at vr underscore east stream
joining us today via Skype is former see
us go pro player and now ely analyst
jason Moses O'Toole Jason how's it goin
man it's going really well you just get
a hang out in this in the set all day
it's it's looking beautiful so no
complaints here how are you guys we're
doing good man thats it does look pretty
awesome so you were from being a pro
player to calling matches and telling
stories on TV s which is pretty amazing
please tell us what's been the biggest
surprise and how's this transitions been
overall for you oh don't see the
transition she's been pretty easy
obviously I turn herself out a lot with
that not everyone looking here alright a
big smile is is it's the first time I've
felt nervous before broadcast at a long
time where those those fridays before TP
yes but but I'm in swim see not once
what's start once you get the cameras
rollin it's the same as any other it's
run a so I mean you really call a rhythm
pretty quickly I just a lot more camera
really yeah it's true there are a lot
more cameras where for television but
like for you in in in hosting this and
being a pro player yourself in the past
and seeing the fans of the community how
our fans transitioning from watching on
twitch to watching on TBS uh that's the
big thing and I well I think 11 part
about it is that eSports fans especially
counter-strike fan since it's such an
old franchise it's been around since
1999 it actually I think yesterday was
seventeen year anniversary you know all
these people that have been watching
this game and playing this game for
years for most of their lives we're just
loyal to any television company that's
coming in and like Turner there they're
making this they're keeping it loyal to
counter-strike we're not trying to
change the game they're just adding
their own flair to it and I think that
draws people to want to watch it on
television it is going to be you know a
little bit of a struggle when it starts
just because streaming is so convenient
but I mean people are loving I get
pictures every day at people at buffalo
wild wings and groups of 20 and 30
people just to watch the boat
yeah man that's what I'm going to say
because of counter-strike it's a no jeez
eastport it's been around for a while
and so transitioning into television and
getting it right the first time I would
imagine is a daunting task but it's been
working out pretty well I've to ask you
this though besides see us go there any
eSports out there that you're playing
right now uh yeah you know actually for
a couple of years now I've been playing
league of legends just for fun which is
another really big title guys save it
hey the different game modes they have
like Arabs and so it's just one of those
things where after a long day I can just
turn the brain off and kind of just and
just you know like oily a little bit I
also overwatch is obviously the next big
exciting game that's come out so plenty
of people play and that and I just get
in and I that's such a plenty to play
with a group of friends I Hugh meaning
an overwatch is your main oh I like uh
you know I've gone with me and then
Reinhardt so like a tanky and then the
ISIS I love may she's so much fun to
play hey May is bae i love i love may
yes so you know there's been a lot of
III announcements that came out last
week including quake champions of
everything that's been announced at e3
what got you the most excited uh well
quit champions is cool that that's
actually a lot of people don't know that
that's like the original FPSes title
from way way back when I don't know if
I'm just really excited to be optimistic
for it just because with such an old
franchise rebooting it yeah I'm trying
to say loyal to those roots there's
gonna be a lot of people expecting big
things from that game so they have a
tall task ahead of them but then you
know otherwise I'm a Nintendo guy at
heart I've always been a Nintendo guy I
play the ocarina of time what's here
it's like tradition hey so the new
Legend of Zelda that have breath the
wild looks sick I got a demo it not to
make you jealous
absolutely gorgeous you're gonna be so
that's what now I'm heartbroken that's
all right definitely worth waiting for
all right Jason we are running out of
time but thank you very much for joining
us and guys you can follow him on
twitter at on fire moses and that's a
wrap for today to get more each stream
and eSports news download Bleacher
Report's team stream app on your phone
and select which specific sports teams
and these sports titles you want to
follow and get updates on tomorrow we're
going to discuss uk's new 24-hour TV
network dedicated to eSports as well as
have three time evo champ Carl perfect
legend white stopping by our set alright
until next time everybody please later